How do I decide between different products
for phase six of the detoxification process?
So if you haven't read my book,
the seven phases of detox, you know,
their home, what this question is about
phase six has to do with proper elimination.
And in the book, and in the course,
I talk about different products that you could use
to help with elimination.
And it is a little bit of a trial and error
because it is, if you are on the course,
I'm not giving you direct advice as, you know,
a patient because we don't have patients,
we have members.
So it is a trial and error.
And it is about looking at other products
that you might already have in the cupboard.
I've got here just to sell products.
I don't want the courses to be just to sell products.
I want you to look at the ingredients of the products
that I recommend and you might have
a cover for the products already.
Well, by all means, try to utilize those products,
but understand, phase six is helping you
with the detoxification pathway.
And phase six is helping you with the limitation
through that path and then piece of that pathway.
Some mistakes that people make as they had somebody
that they asked me why I was taking an allo product
for my gut and it was really helping me
is it the same thing as the allo that you recommend?
Well, I had to look at that product
that they were taking it as not capable.
So there is some, a lot of differences in the ingredients
that might have allo in the name,
but it's the variety of allo that's going to help with elimination.
So just typical allo which would be allo-armorescence
can be very soothing for the intestinal tract.
It can be very healing for the intestinal tract.
The typically isn't going to be really helping
with elimination.
If you want to help with elimination,
let's say you're constipated,
then you really need cape allo.
If you're going to pick the allo product,
that's a specific type of allo.
With magnesium, you have a little bit more leeway.
Magnesium glycinate is typically the product
that might be recommended by a lot of practitioners
if you're dealing with constipation
because it can stay more in the gut
and therefore draw more water, but that's the whole idea.
So excess magnesium of any type,
any variety, any type of chelated magnesium,
if you take excess of it,
it'll end up getting dumped in the gut
and that will draw water and that will help with elimination.
As well, we have multiple products that I recommend.
Some people, their real issue is the deficiency in fiber.
They're just not eating a lot of fiber rich foods.
Salads, data week, vegetables.
It's just their habitual dietary pattern
and it's just a change in diet that can help.
Sometimes you're adding extra fiber
that is a digestible fiber,
which we typically recommend the sun spectrum
or the sun fiber products.
That could be the thing that really helps the person.
Some people are constipated because they have an imbalance
and they're got flora and they really need probiotics.
So I'm all for using any of these products
to help with constipation because you cannot be constipated.
But you do want to dig a little bit deeper eventually
at some point in time to look at why am I constipated?
You know, I'm constipated because of my important diet
or am I constipated because I have a lot of inflammation in the gut?
Do I need to do some other testing to find out
any sources of inflammation that you need to deal with?
Do I need to dig to the reason why?
And I think yes, the answer is the only thing.
Yes.
So do do that.
But do experiment, I can't tell you exactly
what's going to be best for you.
You do need to do some experimentation in this process
is going to.